[Music]
hello still morning it's a CO causal
inference morning so uh before we break
for lunch uh we're going to hear from
Naz uh studying at uh tilb University uh
as a researcher so she's going to talk
about staggered diff and diff in
practice so yes without further Ado
please give a warm welcome to NZ yeah
thank you very
much yes hi hi everyone thanks uh first
of all for joining um uh today I will
talk about difference and differences um
situations where it doesn't it may not
work in in if you use it in a regular
fashion and I'll use a motivating
example from music industry uh before we
get started I want to know who is
familiar with difference and
differences okay quite a bit and have
you applied difference and differences
yourself uh yeah some people
okay well we have so a variety of people
yeah variety of familiarity but I think
everyone uh will be able to take away
something uh from this
presentation before I get into the topic
let me introduce myself a little bit um
You can call me Naz I'm a PhD candidate
in quantitative economics at TU
University and I have a backgrounds in
economics and
econometrics I'll be uh graduating soon
so if you are interested in my stuff uh
or your compan is interested uh I I will
be happy to talk after my
presentation yeah so everyone got the
point um yeah let's get
started
oh right so um as a researcher I was
interested in kind of investigating
economic e economics in music industry
and lately um in the recent times we
came across um this song by uh Kate Bush
called running up that hill um so this
song was originally publ released in
1980s but I am sure a lot of you um and
a lot of people in the world have heard
this song for the first time in the
recent few years um and this was because
um this song was featured in a popular
Netflix show called stranger things like
two years ago and from there this song
um just got a huge boost in popularity
and it's reached number one in many
music charts about 40 years after its
original release so this uh we observed
this and we also observed similar
examples of like songs being featured in
TV series or movies and getting just a
huge boost in popularity and as I am in
marketing I asked okay can we use this
or can the managers in music industry uh
use this um synchron this featuring as a
promotion tool in the music industry the
these are called uh music
synchronizations so these are whenever a
uh song is featured in movies or TV
shows and um in the music industry there
are some very successful examples like
this Kate Bush example that got really a
huge boost but it could also be that
this song and a few other successful
examples are rather outliers and not the
rule so this from this example um I
wanted to invest G what is the impact uh
of Music sync on song popularity on
average and
um if uh you know if I didn't know about
difference and differences let's um be
or in an Ideal World rather in in an
Ideal World um what I will do is some
choose some random songs and um you know
assign these random songs to be featured
in some TV series and uh choose some
random songs not to be featured so that
they will be my
controls um but in this case uh AB
testing is not feasible as you can
imagine it will be really hard for me to
go up to the TV show Runners and say
here I choose uh some random songs for
you why don't you use this in uh your TV
show it's just not possible so um the
next best alternative is to use
observational data um as Kevin kind of
talked about the previous speaker um
what I can do is I have I had a data set
um that had songs uh that are synced in
TV shows and that are not
synced um so basically the idea will be
to kind of in a way compare
these um and I had some outcome metric
that kind of reflects
popularity um we had um the number of
playlist placements for like Spotify
play playlist placements for all of
these songs on a weekly basis so the
idea is that um the more popular as song
is the more playlist it is in and of
course I did some checks to kind of see
if this is actually reflecting
popularity and it was a very reasonable
kind of outcome and it it was the kind
of the best kind of outcome metric that
we could
use and how would I kind of estimate
answer this question the what is the
impact of Music synchronization
on
popularity if I didn't know what
difference and references first idea
that would come to my mind is to just
compare um the outcomes for synced
versus unsynced
songs but imagine like songs like Kate
Bush uh you know running up that hill
they are inherently different from sing
songs that are not synced uh once I kind
of checked out the summer statistics
comparing sync versus unsync songs I
realize you know as expected uh Sync
song songs are different from the unsync
ones usually they are way more popular
from the start um and there could be
many other like Song level
characteristics that could be different
so if I just compare these two groups I
will be ignoring Song level differences
and that could lead to biases in my
estimation of the impact of uh
synchronization um the next idea could
be okay if the uning songs are not good
comparison they are different why don't
I just compare before and after of to
sing songs um the problem with this is
that it ignores any time Trend that
might be happening like across all the
songs maybe all of the songs are
decreasing in popularity or it could be
like there could be some seasonality for
example H at the end of the year
Christmas time Maria Carri song of you
know the all I want you for Christmas
that really get gets a boost in um you
know all of the platforms and also uh it
is is usually synced more so you will be
kind of if you try to estimate uh using
this comparison you will be confounding
the effect of sync with
seasonality uh what is the solution
that's difference and differences so
difference and differences takes uh both
of these things into account and kind of
uh in certain under certain conditions H
it it gives you a good estimation of the
uh treatment effect in this case the
sync um let's get into how um
this uh difference and differences
estimator works so I put a very simple
example this is um two group and two
period case um so I have uh two groups
here represented by uh so these two
songs so Running Up That heeld is the
treatment as you can see the T sign over
there and tazan boy is another song and
this is not synced and it is a
control um as you can see running up
that hill is synced in the second second
period uh for stranger things meanwhile
Taran is never synced so that will be my
control and let's see how difference and
differences estimator Works let's say uh
popularity of running up that hill um
was two units just imaginary popularity
unit um and after the sink um it got
boosted to five right um first a
difference and estimator takes um this
difference so the change is three for
this song The treated song and I will do
the same for Taran boy the control so
the popularity gets uh increases from
one to two and the change here is one um
and what I would what this estimator
does is to basically compare the amount
of changes in treatment versus the
control in this case it will be 3 minus
one two unit of change
uh can be attributable to the sync in
this case just to mention very like um a
core assumption on in all of the
difference and differences methods um is
parallel trans assumption I'm using that
assumption here uh assuming that the
change in uh for running up that hill
will be one if it was not uh synced so
this is an important uh assumption but
you know it's not the focal point of
today but uh it's something to keep in
mind always if you are using difference
and
differences right so I think uh we get
the basic working of difference and
differences but the thing is uh the data
I had with a lot of songs many songs
thousands um I didn't have just two
groups my data looked more like this so
I had more than two uh groups so songs
getting treated at at different times um
and yeah multiple time periods so in
this case I have a simple case uh three
uh groups and three um time
periods so in the first case um what we
have here is again running up that hill
song um and it givs a sync in the second
period so that's the early treated group
and surf time as you can see is the late
treated group tazan boy is never
treated um and you might ask how does a
difference and different estimator will
work in this case because I don't have
um like it's not as simple as before but
what it um what the economet
econometricians found uh this estimator
does in this situation uh is that um it
takes a weighted average of two group
and two period combination um
combination
estimates what do I mean by this I'll
come to
that but I hope um so um this is the
kind of the situation we have how do we
go by kind of estimating the treatment
effect as I said it is 2 by two so the
did estimator we look at the two two by
two combinations where there's some sort
of a status change in terms of the
treatment status so the first case will
be this so the first component of the
weighted average um that will be you
know running up that hill would play the
treatment here and surf time will play
the
control um next component in the
weighted average is this one pretty
similar um yeah there's not much
changing and you will just calculate the
estimated treatment effect as in the
first one and use that as the component
in your waist
average and then later I will look at
the last two periods and two of the uh
different groups here surf time plays
the treatment ton Bo is the
control it was uh good so far but uh it
appears uh this at estimator also uses
this combination uh as one of the kind
of combinations in the treatment effect
estimate
so what we have here is running up that
hill it is already treated so it was
treated in the first between first and
second period but it's plays a the role
of control here because there's no
status change for this one me meanwhile
surf time who's the uh the song that is
uh later treated it plays the treated
group for this estimator first thing to
realize from here is that this
comparison is not very uh intuitive why
would you use uh early treated um song
as a
control but it is it can be and it
that's why this is called forbidding
comparisons and it will cause some
problems and I will show you
how so let's let's say running up that
hill got some initial Boost from the
sink and but later it even you know
things picked up so the popularity went
from 5 to 10 in the second kind of the
exposure period exposure to
treatment um so the difference I would
calculate from this is five and the five
is a change for the control in this
situation and this second case so the
surf time the actual kind of treatment
uh playing a song here um the popularity
increase was not as strong for this song
so there's some heterogeneity so there
are differences between groups and the
popularity went from two to three so the
difference is one and if I compare the
Chang treatment uh to the control so 1 -
5 that is equal to minus 4 so that will
be kind of the component the last
component of your weighted average that
will go into kind of estimating this
treatment effect with uh difference and
differences estimator as you can imagine
the kind of the issues this could cause
even though all of the in Old cases the
synchronization was had a positive
impact um and here too but it is giving
us a negative estimate so in kind of if
this heterogeneity is really high levels
and you know in certain situations um if
you don't do not account for this
variation in treatment timing and if you
do not prevent this uh forbidden
comparisons you might um end up with
with really um biased estimations of the
treatment right so we understand the
problem but thankfully um there are also
some
solutions so as we uh have seen
traditional difference and differences
estimator might lead to misleading
estimates in the cases where there's a
variation in treatment timing and also
like high heterogeneity between
treatment between groups in terms of the
treatment
effects and this is because forbidden
comparison so when you use early treated
group as the
control um what we can do to kind of
address this issue use clean controls so
we can use um the unaffected the unit
units and time periods that are
unaffected from the
treatment and there are a few um methods
that are developed to kind of address
this there are many methods but I think
these are the most commonly used and
they are kind of I think the most
flexible um stagger difference and
differences by calan sna and stack
difference and differences by jenus at
all so uh I'll shortly explain this to
just give you an overview of these
methods uh first staggered difference
and differences by K and Cenna so the
Practical implementation of this is that
this um method calculates the treatment
effect estimates the treatment effect
for each each of the group uh and time
periods uh and then you can aggregate
this to a um group level or exposure to
the treatment or an overall
level in terms of the advantages this uh
method has a um art package called uh
did and it has a very uh transparent
selection of control group so that's
very nice you can see exactly which
units and time periods are used as
controls and it has a lot of like
customization uh
ability the disadvantage is that for
example in my example if you want to
kind of learn how does the effect of
sync changes by song age like is uh do
older songs benefit more from the syncs
for example maybe because they evoke
Nostalgia uh you can't do that with this
method for now um there's no way to kind
of measure heterogeneity uh in the
treatment effect along some Co variat
uh you can do it at the group level Etc
but um or cohort U and it can be also in
like um computationally intensive so
that's a downside but it's pretty uh
good place to start the other option in
my opinion is to use stack difference
and differences how does this work um so
initially you um create a group specific
so treatment group specific data sets
and you kind of in include clean
controls in this l data sets later you
stack these data sets on top of each
other and you create this stack data and
run a modified difference and
differences uh
analysis for this
data um in terms of the
advantages uh it is pretty similar to
traditional difference and differences
um kind of approach but it's a modified
version of this basically where you
choose the controls uh it is
computationally in inexpensive compared
to the previous one and can include um
covariates um to investigate
heterogenity in the you know different
groups the dis disadvantage is that
there's no package for its
implementation but you can kind of
search up some uh sample code on GitHub
so it's not too
bad so let's Tye in everything together
what happened to my um what is my
results from you know trying to answer
this question uh does um syn uh have a
have an impact on music popularity so I
kind of graphed my results estimations
here h on the x-axis I have uh weeks
since the synchronization and minus
numbers are for before the
synchronization zero indicates the week
of
synchronization um and I I grafted it
until four uh weeks after the
synchronization I have the estimates um
so these are I kind of did this um the
outcome is a log number of playlist as
song is placed in and this basically
estim is show the change in the number
of playlist as long as uh kind of placed
in um as you can so I grafted all of the
three kind of approaches calan sna uh
stacked difference and differences and
traditional one in my case so overall as
you might realize the first thing um the
for me it doesn't make much of a
difference
so but it is always good to check it
could have been big differences in my
case it doesn't so what I see here if we
start from the minus period I don't see
any particular uh different Trends in
you know in the outcome for synchronized
songs and the same is true for the after
the sync there are some kind of
difference between um in the week zero
Cal senteno method and and the rest but
that can happen because these um well
compared to the stack um these methods
are similar but not exactly the same so
there are kind of uh the minor
differences can happen so uh overall
answer is that no on average the
synchronizations uh do not benefit the
songs but you know the next step in this
case for me will be to look at different
groups you know is it affecting for
example older songs
better um but that's these are Anis so
what are the takeaways um so difference
and differences can be a powerful tool
in situations where experimentation is
not
practical but if there's a variation in
treatment timing the traditional
difference and differences estimator
might lead to uh misleading
estimates uh and we can avoid this by
using right uh approaches that account
for this variation in the treatment and
uses the right
controls so that was my talk thank you
very much for listening and you can find
um uh my kind of more writings blogs on
this on medium and um yeah I will be
happy to talk to you um if kind of you
are interested in this stuff um yeah
thank
you